obviously for people who don't know the
bear is broken up into a lot of
different parts right you know obviously
there's oakland
uh there's let's go frisco brick yeah
so like what what do you think makes
cause vallejo like i said you know shout
out to like nefta pharaoh 40. leo's a
huge
part as far as just the
historical context of barrier hip-hop
music but what do you think makes
vallejo different than the rest of the
bay i think it's because we're
integrated but also separate you know
like we're very
like once you cross the bridge
everything is kind of together like
emeryville
oakland uh you got like hey where all of
that [ __ ] is like you feel me it's like
connected berkeley it's all like right
there within each other vallejo is like
just it's just us here you you feel me
there's no connection and i think with
that we've been able to develop
everything uniquely because it's like
we're not tied into nothing so
everything that comes out the v is fresh
like it's only here you can only get
this [ __ ] here the sound the style
everything you feel me the sauce like
bro
it's just a different energy you feel me
and people are really prideful about it
as well like you don't meet too many
people from vallejo who isn't like if
you meet somebody from vallejo they're
going to let you know they're from
valencia right no that's for sure that
that [ __ ] gonna come up
period yeah no that's facts or they're
like they're
like shout out my guy ken his instagram
is vallejo cam
like bro he obviously this [ __ ]
in atlanta and he's talking about
vallejo yeah right bro you feel me
because it's really it's it's the water
like we're we're a standalone city you
feel me like to come from frisco you
gotta cross two bridges to get in
vallejo you feel me and we're both in
the bay area but we're just like a
stand-alone city